hoy el presidente hace lenski ha
visitado la ciudad de nikolai e
fuertemente bombardeada en las últimas
semanas y que hace frontera con heart
son una zona ocupada por el ejército
ruso y donde ahora las tropas ucranianas
intentan recuperar territorio la guerra
en este país continúa con ataques con
misiles
aquí friv una zona donde es originario
el propio presidente ucraniano pero
donde se está concentrando la intensidad
de todos los ataques es en la batalla
del donbass está siendo crucial según
información de inteligencia
internacional las tropas rusas estarían
moviendo artillería y batallones de la
zona donde nos encontramos en kharkiv
hacia el donbass hacia esa batalla que
se está librando en sever donés ilicic
ans es muy importante esta batalla y lo
ha dicho el propio negociador ucraniano
porque según sus palabras están
dispuestos a negociar después de que
pase el verano cuando vuelvan a retomar
las posiciones que tenía este país antes
de que empezara la invasión rusa lo
cierto es que sobre el terreno rusia
está avanzando muy